this was personal a diplomat intimidated
Elstad incensed what was your reaction
when you heard the President of the
United States refer to you as bad news I
couldn't believe it I mean again shocked
appalled devastated that the President
of the United States would talk about
any ambassador like that to a foreign
head of state and it was me I mean I
couldn't believe that came a broader
devastating assessment our Ukraine
policy has been thrown into disarray and
shady interests the word of the world
over have learned how little it takes to
remove an American ambassador who does
not give them what they want and just as
she described feeling under threat the
president decided to launch a live
attack tweeting that everywhere Marie
Ivanovich went turned bad what effect do
you think that has on other witnesses
willingness to come forward and expose
wrongdoing well it's very intimidating
deine designed to intimidate is it not I
mean I can't speak to what the president
is trying to do but I think the effect
is to be intimidating his colleagues did
not follow suit ambassador I wanted to
say I have a great deal of respect for
what you do I for one want to thank you
so very much for a long service
exemplary service you're tough as nails
and you're smart as hell instead they
tried to denigrate the day as mere
theatrics unrelated to evidence not
exactly sure what the ambassador is
doing here today the Ambassador is not a
material fact witness to anything any of
the accusations that are being hurled
the fact is these corridors are as
splitters the country but they also
wield the ultimate power Republicans
tried to cast Jovanovic his testimony is
irrelevant because she wasn't on that
call between Donald Trump and Ukraine's
president
Democrats believe her absence goes to
the heart of the impeachment story that
she was deliberately sidelined because
she was seen as an obstacle across town
the president insisted the process would
only elevate his prospects
I think it's considered a joke all over
Washington and all over the world the
Republicans are given no due process
whatsoever we're not allowed to do
anything it's a disgrace what's
happening but you know what the American
public understands it and that's why the
poll numbers are so good and that's why
other things are so good cheers or jeers
boats will deliver the ultimate verdict
not here but at the ballot box
woody Leyland Sky News Washington
[Applause]